President Trump promised Americans a
giant tax cut for Christmas he expressed
confidence again today it's happening
Republicans plan to unveil a final
merged House and Senate bill tomorrow
with the aim of voting sometime early
next week will it pass Republican
Senator Marco Rubio says he's a no
unless the child tax credit for the
working poor is expanded the President
believes the senator will come around we
have tremendous support we have
tremendous
it'll be the largest tax cut in the
history of our country and I will say
the Republican senators and Congress men
and women have been incredible so I
think we will get there to be in a very
short period of time it will be the
greatest Christmas present that a lot of
people have ever received it will be
something special something special
well the Senate's Democratic leader is
calling for the tax vote to be delayed
until Alabama's new senator elect Doug
Jones is seated it would be wrong for
Senate Republicans to jam through this
tax bill without giving the newly
elected senator from Alabama the
opportunity to cast his vote all right
Dana so this is to be expected by
Schumer because of course they don't
want this to go through so anything that
they can do to be obstructionist to
prevent this from being implemented is
to be expected yeah and that's not going
to happen and also I read today that
they said it's like some false deadline
but the Republicans have always said
they wanted to get through this to the
President's desk before Christmas but at
the end of the year and so they've been
right on track and this is before the
Washington Post story came out about Roy
Moore this the deadline that the print
that the Republicans set was after
Obamacare repeal and replace failed so
that's not going to happen they're not
going to wait I think the Democrats was
there trying to find something to say
but I thought today was really
interesting to watch the the president
he's just so close to getting this done
I think it's to be expected that you
would have a couple of members who
really want something to press their
advantage right now because there is
this deadline they do
want a little bit more on the child tax
credit we can debate the merits of that
Ivanka Trump wants that as well so they
know that they have a chance to possibly
get that I don't think that at the end
of this that they will actually not vote
for it there could be a little bit of
room to play with on the corporate rate
because the president wanted 15 agreed
to 20 now it's at 21 go Marco Rubio's
point is well going to 22% is it that
big a deal the corporations are still
gonna be happy and we could actually do
more to help the working poor and I
don't know if that will be persuasive
but it could be with the president all
right so a little bit of the last-minute
negotiations and deal-making Jesse
yeah he's using his leverage and he
probably gonna be effective because the
deadline is fast approaching I think
this deal is much better than what we
saw before I don't love the tax cut it's
not big or bold enough but it's gotten
better in conference they're dropping
the top rate from 39 right now it's a 37
which is going to have a stimulative
effect that's good and 20% better than
25% for the corporate rate reduction
which is also positive and the Obamacare
mandate one that will get repealed and
that is a huge accomplishment for the
Republican Congress no one thought that
was even going to happen and then we had
talked about this people that live in
high-tech states like New York and in
California can be able to deduct your
state and local taxes up to ten thousand
not all of it but up to ten thousand so
that's a good thing so I think this
trains moving towards the station and
it's going to happen and although it's
going to be the best Christmas present
everyone's gonna get because it's not as
generous towards I think lower class and
middle-class Americans it's only about
thirty eight dollars a week but it's
better than nothing you got a lamp when
you say that y1 this is so absurd this
is such a giveaway to the rich you might
as well be more taxes a giveaway to not
only the rich man of the people I'm
gonna take care of the forgotten man the
middle class I'm gonna create that's
what he's trying to do the even the
corporation says is not going to create
jobs absurd and crude and rude and
unfair in the Christmas season but let
me just say there's nothing to what Dana
was talking about this thing is far
shaky er than anybody wants to pretend
all the Republicans want you to say this
is on a train we're leaving the station
it's about to happen it is not only not
only that you have bob Corker rightly as
a true conservative worried about
blowing up the deficit but you have
Marco Rubio now saying hey what about
working people what about the working
poor what about Mike Lee he's on the
edge - what about McCain and Cochran
both of them sick may not be able to
vote and then of course Doug Jones if
Doug Jones gets in there and he's the
rightly elected senator from Alabama and
it's only because Mitch McConnell wants
to play parliamentary games that his
he's seeding is being delayed then all
of a sudden that the math shifts
radically and against this horrible bill
Oh we'll see Danna rebuttal
no I don't think I would add is that
there's another thing that's happening
here though the house always talks about
that they pass all these bills and it
stalled in the Senate actually what
happens the Senate just has a different
procedure the other thing in addition to
the individual mandate getting repealed
that Republicans have wanted for a
really long time and it's not been
possible is drilling in Anwar mm-hmm and
that's actually would be a part of this
bill see the rain they are just
celebrating okay i Greg you know how do
you see it so from you liked it a little
bit better now it's a little bit more
watch that the reindeer are celebrating
I thought it was about two people now
you're worried about the rain that's
good people the more energy-independent
we are the better we are we're more
self-reliant it's better for everybody I
feel bad about the reindeer look all
one's doing is he's doing with the
Democrats do they always block agendas
by using the same tools which is fear
hyperbole bad hair everything's the end
of the world it's the apocalypse
beats Mad Max you know with Apocalypse
Now floater
everything is awful that's why nobody
believes you I don't mean you won but
the but the left
because everything everything is the end
of the world
net neutrality today I swear to God I
thought the end I if you saw the
headlines on CNN the end of the Internet
as you know it everything is and then
and again you can't no Democrat can
accuse anybody of jamming anything right
they spent eight years of jamming stuff
down our throats so we this whole
process has been very slow I think and
be under Trump which is quite possibly
those transparent presidency
I've lived in you see everything it's
not ready it's it's not pretty but
you're learning you learn about the
media how the media lies you learn about
them all the infighting you learn about
the flaws of the presidency you learn
about everything hold on a second you
don't think this thing has been pushed
through and jammed down it's been going
around it's actually big people actually
read this oh no in fact you would think
hypocrisy is absolutely rank on this
given that you complain oh what about
Nancy Pelosi saying you won't you have
to pass it to know what's in it
yes exactly what's the promise the
promise to Rubio is oh don't worry about
it says president Trump will make some
kind of deal it's only because they
don't have any legislative
accomplishment and they're Donna have no
debating about that you have so many
people consumed by Russian collusion and
Palace infighting you say nothing's
happened deregulation pipelines Anwar of
the Paris Accords in tightening
relationships with China India and
Russia repealing the mandate yeah a lot
has been happening so keep chasing
Russia how about complaining about who
gets tough talk about how about all the
unrest in the Middle East thanks to old
Trump
did I want to come to you to talk to you
about Paul Ryan cuz there were some
reports today that House Speaker Paul
Ryan is actually considering leaving
Congress after the midterm elections
here was the White House response to
those rumors
the President did speak to the speaker
not too long ago and made sure that the
speaker knew very clearly and in no
uncertain terms that if that news was
true he was very unhappy with it the
speaker assured the president that those
were not accurate reports and that they
looked forward to working together for a
long time to come okay Dana so White
House communications coming out with a
swift response just the port of Ryan I
mean the president would be unhappy I
mean this is different because if this
had been this news would come out maybe
four months ago the president - oh good
yes okay but I think that we've seen a
couple of things happen that are
different there's been personnel changes
in the White House you see the president
actually think you know wait a second
they are trying to actually pass my
agenda with passing a lot of bills in
the house and then getting some of the
stuff done in the Senate where they can
but also being supportive especially on
judges in particular and then you have
the Paul Ryan's office saying no that's
not happening it's not happening now I
will just say that that's what Speaker
Boehner office said right up until the
day that he made it kind of a sudden
decision that political piece it says
overnight he woke up and he was like you
know what I think I'm good here and he
resigns all of a sudden so I don't think
that's necessarily going to happen but I
think it is interesting and good if
you're a Republican to say okay now they
all look like are they're on the same
team with President Trump as the head
coach and pulling people together if
they do get this bill passed the tax
reform bill with the other pieces that
are in it I think that success will feel
good to them and they'll be able to
figure out what they can do in a second
year which is not a lot legislatively
those are usually the most difficult but
I think they're up against some really
challenging days ahead in the short term
in terms of budget issues spending hours
and and I don't think it's going to be
happy times for Paul Ryan he wants to do
a big cut in terms of entitlement
spending you know so Social Security
Medicare and the like
this is going to be hugely controversial
even among royalty the end of the world
one piece will be crushed under a
steamroller of hate you love you love to
say these things because you want to
rich to just do what they want you also
take it away from Grandma he's actually
helping to make our case had a real bill
Kimberly if it really was tax reform I'd
say America great I do think that you
the president campaigned on a 33 percent
top rate so he wanted to go from 39% to
33% the president and all the
Republicans ran on that that's not what
this bill ready not that it was that 39%
he was okay it should be seven I mean
actually one I think you guys
compromised no big you don't want
anything to go down no no that but first
of all if it was the case that our
economy was struggling with the current
tax rate is great it might been
apparently not yours
you bet this is Ohio's economy there's
so much government it is all-time high
we can afford to give some money back to
the people who earned it them yeah Kevin
these are screwed you're greedy if you
want to keep part of your page oh yeah
more taxes voluntary ops there you just
saw it wrong got crushed